Diabetes
Coronary disease.
Autoimmune disease.
Obesity.
Cancer.
Pretty much all chronic
diseases of the western world
are associated with a gut microbiome
that is unhealthy.
The good news is we
can actually heal our gut.
This class is an exploration
of the universe inside you
and how your gut
impacts your mind,
your body and your life.
The microbiome is so
integrated in all aspects of health,
including mental health.
We've realized that
things like moods and behaviors
can be dictated by the
microbes in your gut, so
we want to nurture them.
We actually harbor
more microbes in our bodies
than we have human cells.
The question is, how do you
foster diversity for better health?
Well, to me, the
answer is fermentation.
Smells so good.
Kimchi is just this superfood.
Everyone should know
how to make kombucha
because of
how simple it is.
Put your hand on your belly
now and take a deep breath in.
That will change the
habitat of the microbes.
It's a mind-body technique.
and this is